[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
one time on a flight this was like 2019
i was on a flight i was reading a book
and at the name of the book is the nazi
symbiosis and it has a big swastika
okay on the side and i was reading it
and it's about it's about how the whole
time you're just going
dying laughs no no no it's i think i've
told this story once on did i probably
told the story once on
another podcast but it just what you're
saying this
is a real thing i was sitting next to a
woman
i didn't realize you know i was always
in the aisle seat so she was she could
see the cover because i was like that
and there was a part in this book the
nazi symbiosis which is really about
it's kind of like about nazi and like
the eugenics and like
how like the mind how their minds turned
into doing what they did it's like a
it's like follows that
so one part but they would talk about
like the the horrors of the holocaust
and there's a part
in the holocaust where they it's not
funny
well you're laughing already no no no no
no no
they wanted to like hitler and and and
goebbels
himmler and well gerbils the propaganda
minister himmler was like really like
right
they were the ones like doing like the
experiments and they had one experiment
where they wanted to
they were going to try to like invent
something where like nazis could fly
like some type of like flying power so
they would they would take
members like jewish members you know
people in the holocaust and in like this
big slingshot
shut up i swear to god like throw them
up into the air with like this potion
and they would all just like what to see
if they could fly
with this thing because they would do
all these experiments and they would
fall
what like i'm talking about like a
hundred yards in the air and then they'd
fall and obviously died
and when i was reading it like it was so
shocking to me that i was like
like almost like repulsed by and like
laughing and this woman
at the end of the flight was like you
know i just thought it was a little
inappropriate
that you were giggling in that book and
i want to know what that was about and i
just explained
i've told the story before and i
explained to her that hey like the nazis
were putting injecting
members of the holocaust like this magic
potion and putting them in a slingshot
and throwing them up into the air and
yeah they were falling on the floor so
it's horrible but i thought it was funny
and she was like you know someone in my
family kill was killed in the holocaust
i don't think anything
about that book was funny and i was like
nothing about the holocaust is funny
like zero
about the holocaust that's funny i was
like but that you know like that's why i
was laughing at that
shouting people they were slingshotting
people into the air
and then just standing there and like
this one didn't work
that was so insane you know and so
try it again yes get it out of honey
reload
back then like you know like with um you
know with the with the vikings
they allegedly they invented [ __ ] on
the chest the [ __ ] on the chest
was the thing that the uh what is it
called uh uh schweifenheitzer
schweifen schreifen films [ __ ] yeah they
were the
viking chiefs of films of films what
they would do
is the if they would come and rape and
pillage your land they would take the
the fight the conquering head viking
would go to the other one the one that
they just conquered and they
sit you down in front of your wife and
children and they [ __ ] on your chest to
say i'm the dominant one
i just [ __ ] on your kids gotta see dad
get pooped out kids gotta see that
kid's gotta see that they're playing
with a toy and that's the thing too
people wanna yell you're constipated and
you can't [ __ ] like that would be funny
just gotta wait for a long time
he's just like i got nothing like one
minute one more minute
oh he's just farting on your chest
he's just laying there like please sir
just finished or you dude you just hit
him with a bunch of rabbit poop just
pellets on the chest
i'm more embarrassed yeah [ __ ] on his
chest i'm like i don't i don't really
want to i i don't think that's is that
do it do it okay just
[Music]
[Laughter]
you're like i've been eating a lot of
yogurt you guys call it skier
[Laughter]
my parents we joke all the time right
they're like yeah we're not gonna leave
you a [ __ ] dime you know
even if they had money the joke is we
would never right so i
my dad's gambling it on the [ __ ] you
know nashville predators
might get my my dad gamble too he always
get but my dad would never gamble like
on the yankees he would always
like he lost my mom's savings life
savings which is 10 g's but that's still
a lot of money in 1984.
he gambled around the montreal expos can
i say something i just was about to make
a joke about the expo so i was like what
have you [ __ ] been on the expo
yeah no it's my dad gambler and my dad
gambled on my gender when i was born he
had to pay my
uncle 500 bucks the doctor the the
doctor's like it's a boy he's like it's
a girl 10 jesus
said tuck it back talk it back
put it back in yeah because yes uh
yesterday uh or whenever this comes out
andrew
let me on his podcast whiskey ginger
thank you very much and i told everybody
that i was gay and i said i was being
very serious and i'm not
i'm a heterosexual male yeah i just want
to let everyone know i was kidding
around but i am i am not
i am a straight male now why do you
think people think you might be gay
um because i looked in the camera you
sit up straight
yeah because i looked in the camera on
the podcast the other day and said it
was gay but i am not gay so i want to
say nope
i'm straight okay but there's a few
things that might give it away that you
might be gay what is that you got good
skin you got straight teeth you wear
jewelry you are nice and in great shape
you're always at the gym you only hang
out with dudes
yes all right i'll tell you why you're
gay why can't i tell you guys
yes because um when i see dudes like you
that are like um
you know handsome with your body size
you know what i mean you're a handsome
it goes there's people ahead of you it
goes dane cook
it goes dangerous uh a couple of people
but i know a couple of different
microbes on you right your friend right
here
yeah he's handsome guys take off his
head look at this look at this guy's
hairline
it doesn't where does it start oh
look at how hairy he is oh [ __ ] no bobby
don't bobby don't bother me no [ __ ] up
[ __ ] you dude oh [ __ ] my dick
you take out good hair like that i'll
suck it up
can i finish my point yeah please let me
finish my point okay
usually that doesn't look like him right
they bully me a bit right they go hey
little my little hop sing
they always say that yeah put me in a
little absolutely give me a noogie right
he's like gentle gentle yeah he's soft
gay oh that's why yeah but no i
don't you're not aggressive i'm not
aggressive i don't know i've
like i said on the podcast the other day
i i don't know that i'm gay but i will
say confidently that
i i i have sex with women but i fall in
love with men
so i would i would i would very much i'd
i'm mostly gay i'm emotionally gay yeah
yeah
but and yeah so but and i have nothing
against the gay community
at all nothing against support and like
the gates well but i am not gay
i'm not gay okay i do but i'm not gay
but i am a democrat so i don't know
but you're because they're mostly gay
democrats
what do you think the percentage of
democrats that are gay i've i thought a
hundred percent oh all of it like like
somebody
somebody bobby's a dem what bob's a damn
yeah but bob's gay he
told me he's gay like somebody the other
day some of the dad was walking and he's
like oh and they said the f4 they're
like you [ __ ] f's and i was like oh i
thought i was like i'm if i was like a
democratic
rally or something like that right i was
like those guys vote for joe biden which
is fine
that's fine who are you going to vote
for huh who are you going to vote for
uh in the november election yeah uh
d-o-n-a-l-d
[Laughter]
see
do you know caitlyn jenner is running
for uh mayor
know that i'm trying to move things
around where i can get a legal law
governor governor give her a vote
governor
republican government okay so here's
what's crazy she's running as a
republican she's always been a
republican
she's against gay marriage
where do we live i love it she's a
transgendered
famous person who's against
a part of a community that she is a part
of right lgbtqia
or what is it now it's lgbtqia whatever
and i mean i'm not saying this in a
disrespectful manner obviously i don't
know all the acronyms now because
they've just added some new
she's a part of this community and she's
against it
yeah that's the craziest craziest thing
i've ever heard in my [ __ ] i don't
care that she's a republican i'm not
saying that means as much
i'm saying how can you be against gay
marriage i don't understand when you get
super honey what's the thing that
triggers it for you what's
cause guys have the two where you're
like no i want to have sociality right
now this has to be there's a trigger you
know
yeah for me i'm trying to think like
what really gets me [ __ ] horned up
um i guess for me like any time
like i like older latino women so if i
see like a latino woman in like her 40s
or 50s
i get horned up i like i like an older
abuela you like like a grandma
yes yes that's what i like so what i've
been doing yeah so what i'll do is i'll
go to like where they're doing the um
because you know new york same rules as
here
i'll go like they're like latino
communities i'll go and i'll go to work
where they're given the vaccines because
it's a lot of 65 and overs yes and i'm
[ __ ] called over there i'll get
horned up and i'll go up sex yeah
yeah 65. google caitlyn jenner uh i want
to see like her did she have a
government website like
i'm running for you know you know
sometimes they do that
yeah like a campaign website yeah that's
what it is
let's see and by the way we're going to
get you out of here
i think caitlyn jenner is hot yeah i
like her as a woman a lot
yeah not as a man oh see look there it
is caitlyn for california
caitlyn needs an honest leader with a
clear california need sorry
california needs an honest leader with a
clear vision our campaign will be
powered by
everyday californians who deserve
leadership and accountable to them so
look at this the donate box
50 is jumping at you it's saying pick me
pick me
please don't do five should we donate
250. let's donate to her i'd give her
give her look at that number look at how
weird this number is
525 50 100 500 1 000 5000 10 000
and then 32 400.
you [ __ ] up on the website
is that is that like a number she needs
left that's like that's all we need to
pay off this gambling debt
yeah yeah i can't believe baylor won
this doesn't make any [ __ ] sense
should we give her should we give her
25. let's do make this a monthly
recurring donation so
make it monthly and just do the 32 400.
yeah let's do it
do you ever feel like that's a that's an
unjust world when you hear that
someone's parents were super successful
and then also they also get very
successful that bums me out a little bit
like like in one sense like well like
his parents are here
his parents are both no it's not
everything is not fair but i just get
bummed that my parents are poor and dumb
that i'm like why didn't i get rich
smartphones oh yeah
dude my mother my mother had me when she
was 21 years old my mother was in
columbia law school
i mean my mother i'm sorry columbia
undergrad school on her way to you know
potentially she want to be a lawyer so
my mom's an ivy league student
and um my father is a criminal my father
actually like and i'm not saying that
like i'm talking about like my father
was in federal prison
when i was a child and they met at a
walkathon
my mom was walking in the walk-a-thon it
was like a school event
and they were raising money for cancer
research and my dad was doing community
service
on the side of the walkathon like a
prison halfway house work release
program
because he just got out of federal
prison picking up garbage
on the side of the road and my mother
had a lapse of judgment wanted a bad boy
in her life and had sex with this guy
and got pregnant
and that's my dad that's your life well
my mom could have
[ __ ] married giannis dad did they get
married or no oh well yeah because my
mother's catholic so the catholic girl
they got married they got immediately
divorced
they got divorced when i was one same oh
cool yeah
yeah got divorced my dad's also a
criminal by the way yeah oh there he
goes but what's your dad what would your
dad go away for
it was like um like racketeering money
laundering he was like a bookie
mine was drugs they're they're all
dirtbags cheers man cheers
what does it feel like yeah what does it
feel like doing in the butt
uh it hurts at first her or you
oh okay oh i don't okay well what do you
say because you received um
tap that back what does it say we put in
a lady's buttocks i put it into a shh
yeah shout out toshi sushi.com
uh what does it feel honestly it feels
um it
you know what's so [ __ ] up about it
this is me being like a sensitive guy
but i know it's
and i know it hurts her yeah like you
know it hurts
but unless they've done it a bunch
before and a few times that hurts you
right and then you and then you're like
oh because you can hear it it's like
hitting a triangle like
you play operation with the sides
when it's new and it was new uh two out
of the three times
it you uh you could tell it was
extremely uncomfortable and painful and
you're like this isn't fun there's no
way it's
the guy on the way on the way in was
watching game of thrones
he was a really cool dude we started
chat and he was a baseball scout for the
cincinnati reds oh sweet yeah and he
gave me can you be on the team because
you have red hair
he said yes wow he said yes i asked he
said yes i said my buddy chris is going
to want to know when i get back to
you if i could be on the team and he
said you got it kiddo you gave me his
card so i think i'm pitching next week
great i got to go to nettie i want to
come he said he's uh
he's he was watching game of thrones and
he had and he had it tilted a little bit
and uh he was talking about the f1 show
and he was like that's great he's like
i'm watching game of thrones but i gotta
be careful on a plane because you know
there's a lot of nudity on the
on the show and i'm like well you're you
know you're good you're good for me and
he was like yeah but you know
i've had it where like a kid is looking
through the crack
you know behind like just like a little
like a little perfect yeah
and he goes i had to like put my elbow
up through to block the seat
otherwise you have to turn to the dad
and be like hey dude he's getting some
titty education right now yeah yeah
you do all the legion of skank stuff
yeah legion of skanks but you know
legion of skanks
legion of skanks the problem is i get so
comfortable in there because they're so
debaucherous [ __ ] absolute scumbag
people louis you know puerto rican round
snake just scum
of the earth he admittedly you know
he admits it i just get in such a
disgusting place mentally that i've said
things that i've ruined
relationships with my family like i've
mentioned things about my
family where they've called and had sit
downs and been like
like my mother they were talking truly i
was like
being excommunicated from my family
because something i said on legion of
skanks
what did you say that was i can't even
repeat it i'll tell you after
but it's just it was so bad say it and
we'll cut it and i just [ __ ]
no dude it's like members of my family
were like we're gonna sue you how would
they know they listen to the show
because the [ __ ] people listen and
then somebody sends them
something like a cousin you have a young
cousin who sent me right and it's so
interesting because
you know one of my one of my you know
family members a girl was like oh my
these guys told me because they're
looking out for me like no they're not
they're trying to [ __ ] get pity from
you so they can hook up with you
yeah what don't you understand idiot but
she's you know
but this is why women can't run the
country that you that's one of the
primary reasons why
you you why have you so often stood on a
platform
to make it so that women can't vote
again um you've said this so many times
you said suffrage was a mistake
and women shouldn't be able to vote now
why is that you think
are you afraid of women's votes yeah i
just think that uh
i just think like show me one example in
history where they ever voted for
something and it's and it's been
the right move oh okay so prior to
women's voting
we were on a good track 100 okay i mean
look in the middle east i mean they
don't have any [ __ ] problems
right yeah and you know and look at what
the men have done the men
i don't know that there's no way the
covet 19 numbers are high
in countries like iran and iraq because
they've been women they've had [ __ ]
face covers for millennials
since the beginning can't get in there
dude if you if you
if you could change one thing about
america today what is it one thing you
can only switch one thing
what is it if i could change one thing
um i'd like to go back to the original
13 colonies
you want this thing let's get rid of
let's anything west of western
can you name the 13 colonies new york
new jersey
maryland um virginia
north carolina south carolina
georgia connecticut
vermont what do we got
uh nine pennsylvania ten
um massachusetts eleven
uh new hampshire twelve
and no but i don't know i because it
gets tricky i always forget if
if maine or rhode island is thirteen
[Music]
[Music]
just the wrong way